happy 1st of September it is Friday's
time for the top 5 news stories of the
whole entire week from GameSpot au HQ
lots of abbreviations there well also a
radiation of two stories to lots of
stories if you've missed any of our news
episodes this week you can go back and
watch them or I mean you can just stick
with us for the next five six seven
minutes how long is it gonna be we don't
know yet because we don't script this
episode let us know what you think down
in that comment section I will ask you
to do that again at the end
popke now is that we care about this
week this one's a bit of a local story
but I think it's got some worldwide
flavor zach-bots the freshman Hall has
been rated R 18 in Australia which means
it's made it through our senses with no
cost and that's kind of a significant
thing it's kind of shocking it's a super
video I mean when you consider you know
2013 the stick of truth was heavily
edited there were some anal probing
scenes among others that didn't make it
through and they had a funny little you
know censorship image with a crying
koala so there's not gonna be any of
that this time that was 100% uncut 100%
uncensored which is really interesting
and there's it'll be interesting to see
what content the whole game actually has
and how like edgy and questionable it
might be yeah yeah we've seen so far
from the trailers and stuff it looks
like it's going to struck much of the
same tone as the first game so it makes
me wonder why the first one couldn't get
through under an r18 I mean yeah that's
obviously like a very straightest
Pacifica we had problems recently at
lost too obviously got hit with the
sense of banhammer and then you know
there was the question of changing a
little bits and pieces so it come
through and it could be released III
haven't I've we spoke to the devs of
South Park a fracture pothole at 83 and
they implied nothing's been turned back
they didn't feel like they had to cut
anything so it must be something on our
end but I'm glad we're getting the full
game with some room so a bit of a
history lesson for those of you that
don't know Australia's had a really
weird relationship with video games and
classification until about five years
ago we only had an M a 15 plus rating
was the highest you could get a game
rated in Australia so anything that was
classed
not appropriate for a 15 year olds with
banned basically you couldn't get it the
only way to get it was by reporting and
then that was
sort of a bit of a illegal thing to do
you weren't supposed to have it stuff
like manhunt got banned here stuff like
gta3 gta1 CD got banned and then they
were edited until they could come here
so it's interesting to see this one get
through the stick of truth obviously
didn't get through under an r18 and now
fractured but whole has so it's gonna be
interesting to see the differences and
if there are at any actual differences
but games can still be banned for things
like sexual violence and stuff like that
which is what happened to outlast 2 so
mostly I'm just looking forward to more
South Park stories that we do on use and
these guys say phrases that I then have
to wonder whether or not I'm gonna bleep
so let's see what happens in the Edit
you guys might not know this but people
can be Jeff wait a minute people can be
jerks in real life right now and since
in check we stole that my gosh anyway so
this has become a problem in a lot of
video games
right now we're specifically talking
about overwatch and they're addressing
it yeah so a game director Jeff Kaplan
wrote in a forum post this week that
they are taking a number of steps to you
know combat and try to make it a better
more wholesome on the environment is
never gonna be a hundred percent rate
it's just just the nature of an online
game but they have short-term goals
medium-term goals and long-term goals
and you know one of those is giving
players more feedback about when you
when you report someone to get an email
back saying you know action has been
taken so you feel like you know the
system is working yeah they're also
gonna be increasing the length of
suspensions so you know that will
hopefully incentivize players to not be
jerks if they know that you know
suspensions can be longer and they're
also going to implement you know
lifetime bans for repeaters so they're
really you know trying to crack down on
that more and you know another angle to
it too is that they are thinking about
you know putting in system such that
rewards players for actually you know
having good behavior which is not
something you always see so I mean there
are two sides to tech to it you know you
know Kaplan spoke very frankly about it
that's good yeah better voice they're
very upfront and tell you everything
that's happening just like how their
thoughts and lots of changes this week a
bunch of characters serve Roadhog now he
can heal while moving to get him into
the action and make him even harder to
kill bleep oh my god my favorite junk
rat and
as to concussion lines so I would be
jumping around those Maps raining death
from above David can never play against
me because I'm super annoying
Arisa has had her shield changed so now
the shape of a shield it covers from
below as well now so that's really handy
and to go with a new deathmatch mode and
French set Chateau map Widowmaker has
had some changes she can now a grapple
book a lot more often and her poison
mine will mark enemies and she can see
them through walls so that's all pretty
cool stuff but you should really check
out overwatch deathmatch it's pretty fun
if you're a destiny veteran and you're
hoping that you get some kind of reward
for having played the first game and
destiny to you're going to sweet what
man that story it was fast I don't know
yet Oh it'll be something it's gonna be
something I mean Luke Luke Smith said in
a video this week that you know if you
play the first game and coming back to
the sequel you're going to get something
so we all played the first game so we're
gonna go back we're gonna find out what
it is I assume it's gonna be an envelope
that has two it's gonna be something
cosmetic I mean nothing nothing what we
don't know what we do know or at least
think we know Kotaku has reported the
deals be details for the first DLC pack
the destiny 2 is gonna have have dropped
apparently so if you don't want to know
anything we are gonna be talking about
it for the next 20-30 seconds it's
called the curse of Osiris so basically
it revolves around you may remember the
walk
Isis Osiris mess with the darkness get
the horns that's what I'm sure yeah that
was mercury can't get enough of that
play so basically it sounds like the
story details are gonna be you need to
save them from the backs but there's
more than that there's gonna be a new
social space at the Lighthouse on
Mercury and you could only get two if
you're successful in the trials visage
and destiny wonderful so that's pretty
interesting I never go to the lighthouse
cuz I'm terrible at PvP yeah so I'm
interested to actually see what victory
looks like yeah well you'll be able to
do because not only can you go to
lighthouse you can then go down to the
planet itself and you'll be able to do
like missions and quests down there and
stuff like that so it sounds like that
area is gonna be way more active this
time around we don't know yet if it's
gonna be a raid how much it's gonna cost
when this DLC is gonna come along what
we do know is their whole strategy is
that they want to provide more content
more often than they did with deaths
anyone so I reckon we can expect it
coming this
definitely I mean when you think about
one of the learnings Activision and
Berkeley talked about was that they just
didn't release content fast enough and
so for the sequel they're bringing in
you know outside studios like Neversoft
and hi moon too you know assist with
Bungie
in that so that distributed development
style is gonna be a little bit different
it's not around but it should lead to
more content faster and obviously
destiny 2 is out next week so make sure
you're subscribed because we're gonna be
just smashing out videos about destiny
to everything you'll need to know it
will be right here on GameSpot so make
sure you subscribe so you don't miss any
of that yeah this little buddy is
discontinued not a little buddy it's
really heavy I'm gonna put down no one
so Microsoft have officially stopped
manufacturing the original Xbox for me
yeah yeah this was the launch model that
came out in 2013 you know heavily
criticized you know I had every unit
came with a Kinect which made the price
more expensive relative to PlayStation 4
so it did not get off to the start that
Microsoft would have wanted they
eventually you know remove the Kinect
requirement and then offered more
recently the Xbox one s which is smaller
has an internal power supply HDR 4k it
seems like things are back on track yeah
that internal power supply is such a
huge thing for Xbox because no Xbox
before the Xbox one s had an internal
power supply always had that gigantic
goddamn power break yeah it's also worth
noting too that you know this is just a
natural part of the life cycle I mean
obviously they're going to discontinue
the original models as they focus on
newer things and think of newer things
the X plus one X comes out in November
so you know they have they're already
two consoles so supporting free in that
way it was probably something that they
were never going to do anymore oh yeah
definitely
although can I say my original fat ps3
still works never replace it and ever
the skinny one it's fine it's obviously
still almost impossible to get your
hands on a Nintendo switch in some parts
of the world here it's ok so it's hard
for me to kind of fathom that but yeah
apparently in the u.s. it is still
really hard to pick one up which is
great for the entender but not good for
people who want to get to have a voice
absolutely but good news we heard this
week that Nintendo is going to be
ramping up production
it remains to be seen you know specific
units and everything but the
spokesperson for the company told the
Wall Street Journal that they are trying
to do everything they can to meet the
demand coming into this holiday season
obviously very very busy time
we're shopping and the worst thing that
could happen would you know to be
completely sold out I have nothing else
to get one underneath the tree or
however you celebrate so there would
there was a specific number shown in
there that said 18 million units that
they were going to produce film on
whether or not that is for this specific
season or the current fiscal year
remains to be seen but clearly they are
doing more to get more consoles into
stores and obviously with those new
consoles that are coming out a whole
bunch of new games were just announced
coming to switch yeah this week's been
really intense they've told us all about
the Indies then in Tendo indie games
that they seem to be going really hard
on just today which is well yesterday
for you guys watching this on Friday
there was the announcement that
oxen-free is coming which is one of the
best indie games in recent years in my
opinion that's gonna be great No More
Heroes brand new No More Heroes system
an all-white form or No More Heroes
I love ya we also heard about a new
super meatboy game coming up super
meatboy forever and the really cool
thing about that is it's gonna be first
on switch really really big because I'm
obviously those games came out on xbox
360 back in the day what else is really
exciting is these are only the tip of
the iceberg there's seventeen and Mindy
titles that they announced this week and
that appears to just be the start of
everything that they're gonna be rolling
out so you know Nintendo has their games
probably proving to be less true for
this switch which is great it's nice to
see it pull back up towards what we've
been seeing I was learning in mark
Sophie is but that's really great so if
you haven't got a switch yet something
apply on it don't forget tomorrow's exam
okay okay that's a lot sorry um Eddie do
doubt her
good that's gonna be great
normal here is brand new normal here is
a system panel white for more nerville
heroes I love No More Heroes
we also learned about a new Travis
touchdown game so there's no more heroes
[Laughter]